I like to think that our job as Leaders
is not to motivate people but to inspire
them I believe in hiring motivated
people and then giving them something to
work towards we can motivate people all
kinds of ways with carrots and sticks
incentives or disincentives but
inspiration is something different it's
the pursuit of something larger than
ourselves feeling like we're a community
feeling like we're doing something
together and you can see this the most
successful organizations we look to our
colleagues and our co-workers and we
trust each other we feel like we have to
do this together uh compared to an
organization where there's poor
leadership and it's only external
motivations like money or bonuses and
everybody sort of is in it for
themselves they may like each other but
they're not incentivized or desired to
help each other
so that is the job of leadership
leadership is responsible for inspiring
the people so there's multiple things uh
Number One Vision where are you going
it's like trying to get people to get
into a car with you but not telling them
where we're going you're more likely to
get them to get in the car if you tell
them where you're going vision is where
we want to take the organization in
terms other than success or customer
service anything like that but literally
how do we imagine a world that doesn't
exist this is what vision is that's why
we call it Vision we can see it in our
imaginations
another part of it is the ability to
communicate Believe It or Not
communication is a huge part of good
leadership we're social animals the way
we express love or friendship is with
words and so too good leaders find words
that capture their Vision but also make
people feel seen and heard and then
that's the third thing empathy people
are human beings we all want to be seen
heard understood we all want to feel
like we're part of something bigger than
ourselves
we want to be seen as human beings we
have Ambitions and Egos and our good
leaders they they know all of that and
they consider that